la france décidément terre d'accueil au
mois d'août puisque c'est dans l'ariège
que tony blair premier ministre
britannique a choisi de passer en
famille une semaine de vacances le
village de saint martin d'oydes moins de
200 habitants au compteur c'est ainsi
muer en capitale par intérim du royaume
uni jeff vite un bear alain location ce
sont les spécialistes de la couronne
britannique
il affirme tony blair chérie tu son
épouse et leurs trois enfants sont
aujourd'hui plus recette que la famille
royale elle mme les habitants de
saint-martin doig sans les premiers
comptes
c'est en quasi vedette de cinéma nuée de
photographes et de caméras comprise que
le premier ministre britannique a donné
ce matin ses premières impressions sur
le petit village d'ariège où il vient
pour la sixième fois le plus les gens
ici c'est très sympa on a créé bien
passer des vacances et je suis très
content des prêts ici en corne et pour
visiter tous les secteurs y est le
premier de ses sites entre guinée en
tout cas de la première vague des
immuables
c'est l'épicerie vous avez ici où il
vient tous les jours quand il est en
vacances
il fait presque partie de la famille
madame je crois que je ne la connais pas
reconnu mais monsieur leproux s'était
élevée en tout cas la diplomatie n'est
jamais très loin même en vacances tony
blair ni
le simple touriste des étés précédents
aujourd'hui il faut parler j'aime
beaucoup la france et je suis très
heureux ici et j'espère que les
relations sont bonnes à matignon il n'en
dira pas plus mais c'est en principe en
fin de semaine que lionel jospin dont le
fief cintegabelle et à quelques
kilomètres rendra visite à son homologue
l'avenir de l'europe en tête de liste
les deux premiers ministres ne manque
pas de sujets de discussion l'entente
cordiale passera par cette maison de
vacances